et
dans le cadre de la campagne d'éducation
des shadoks que nous avions promis au
début de notre feuilleton nous allons en
discuter au premier tour de logique
shadok professeur jadot qu au programme
les passoires
on appelle passera tout instrument sur
lequel ne peut définir trois cents ans
en l'intérieur l'extérieur et l'époux
l'intérieur est généralement placés au
dessus de l'extérieur et se compose le
plus souvent de nouilles et dont les
trous ne sont pas importants en effet
une expérience simple permet de se
rendre compte que l'on ne change pas
notablement les qualités de l'instrument
en réduisant de moitié le nombre des
trous puis on réduise en cette moitié de
moitié etc etc et à la limite jusqu'à ce
qu'il n'y ait plus de trous du tout tout
et or m
la notion de passoire est indépendante
de la notion de trous et réciproquement
on n'appelle pas soir du premier ordre
les passoires qui ne laisse passer ni
les nouilles ni l'eau on n'appelle pas
soir du second tour dhr les passoires
qui laisse passer et les nouilles et
l'eau on n'appelle pas soir du troisième
ordre ou passoire complexe les passoires
qui laisse passer quelques fois l'une ou
l'autre et quelquefois pas pour qu'une
passoire complexe laisse passer l'eau et
pas les nouilles
il faut et il suffit que le diamètre des
trous soit notablement inférieur au
diamètre des nouilles pour qu'une
passemar complexe laisse passer les
nouilles et pas long il faut il suffit
que le diamètre des trous soit
notablement inférieur au diamètre de
l'eau quant aux passoire du premier rang
qui ne laisse passer ni les nouilles ni
l'eau il y en a 2 200 les passoires qui
ne laisse passer ni les nouilles ni
l'eau ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre et
celle qui ne laisse passer ni les
nouilles ni l'eau que dans un sens
seulement c'est pas soir là on les
appelle des casseroles il y a trois
sortes de casseroles les casseroles avec
la queue à droite les casseroles avec la
queue à gauche et les casseroles avec
pas de queue du tout mais c'est là on
les appelle des autobus
il est à trois sortes de thau bus les
autobus qui marchent à droite les
autobus qui marchent à gauche et les
autobus qui ne marche ni
côté ni de l'autre mais ceux là on les
appelle des casseroles il y a trois
sortes de casseroles les casseroles avec
la cure à trotte les casseroles avec
talent
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]